[Music]
okay we're gonna redo Ally to battle
angel again real quick we saw that one
the other day but the video came out
[ __ ] yeah check this better background
anyway um I laid a battle angel I
recommended it was a good movie watching
it I was kind of like thinking to myself
man if I was back you know you know 10
years old 9 years old like I was back in
1977 this would have impacted me enough
as much as Star Wars a new hope I would
love that movie yeah the thing about a
lead of battle angel like I said I
haven't read that it's based on a manga
I guess I haven't you know and it's
James Cameron was involved he was had a
producer credit on stuff like that it
really has that kind of mythic kind of
feel to it yeah it feels like it's very
yeah it's very epic very huge journey
obviously they're setting up a sequel
I'm assuming it might be a trailer has
to be yeah yeah because they left a lot
of open up and she completes one part of
the mission but they're still locked yes
I mean if you've seen the trailers you
know kind of the gist of the story you
know he the doctor played by Christoph
Waltz he finds you know a head
essentially of a cyborg that has a human
brain that's still alive and finds it in
a junkyard puts it in a box they sit in
a body and as the as the movie goes on
like I'm not gonna spoil his remember
who she is she doesn't remember anything
about her former life you know but they
they know where she came from roughly
but they don't know what she did before
that and so as the movie goes on you
kind of learn more and more about who
she was before
yeah and it's kind of interesting too
because this is one of those movies
where you know the more it goes on like
you learned secrets about her but she
wasn't one secret to other the other
characters as well and in history of the
role that they were in and the story
just kind of deepened
deepens it goes in like you think it's
gonna kind of be one way and then
expands the yes out it it looks like a
movie that's just about some cute girl
kicking ass and they call her battle
angel she got big eyes that's not what
it's really about yeah that's a very
very superficial she's got big eyes and
you find out there's a reason why she
has a bit guys
she's the battle angel she's a real
battle angel and figure out why you know
how are they show you why it's it's a
it's a badass movie the character
leaders very much kind of like a Luke
Skywalker with that same hero's journey
things very pure of heart type of a good
person you know and she has to go off
though these trials and a lot of it is
kind of moralistic trials which you know
when you see the movie it's good there's
there's character development in it yeah
a lot of bad [ __ ] happens yeah and she
were she starts to remember who she was
you know yeah yes history starts coming
back to her right and you know it's
she's not a badass by accident and you
know I love the movie was good and it I
loved the movie yeah it was it's up
there with some of my favorites or
something with Mad Max fury roads up
there with like you know Empire Strikes
Back it's a it's that good I thought it
was shot beautifully also yeah it was
beautiful just the whole iron City which
is you know the name of the place where
most of it takes place just everything
had kind of a little bit of a blade
Blade Runner go to it um but it's also
it's kind of its own thing the
storytelling was good all the characters
in it were good there was no like what's
a good way of putting it it was just
very kind of like Greek mythology type
of thing like yeah very much kind of
like morality tales and it's like kind
of old-school in that way it's the guy
who did this you know yeah Cameron he's
done a lot of good movies then it's the
guy who owns it was an el rey channel
and dip predators you know to me he's
has a pretty good track record record
making the products this is it there's a
good story man it's almost kind of
old-school to me yeah well it does seem
like ya seem to be getting back to that
kind of get back to the core what
storytelling was yeah and this was a
very good story it was very unlike I
said they they left it open I mean it's
a contained story she gets to a certain
point but they left a lot of things open
yeah because I imagine that this is
gonna do really really well I mean I
think yeah battle angel is a Valkyrie
that's what they're talking about and
that's what she is
yeah and if and it's not just something
you'll find out when you see her so
there's some of there's like some kind
of Viking shooting there's like yeah
ology and there's a Paradise Lost
Buddhist type stuff in it since ki Adam
mixture who's almost common is a Blade
Runner Star Wars Conan the Barbarian all
that kind of mixed in there Conan the
very first Conad movie there's some of
that same mythos ism that you see in
there
you
okay we just got done seeing a happy
death day - it's the second part of a
series of course or when we called - but
it's about this girl named tree who's a
college student who gets caught in this
damn time loop and she gets killed
there's this murderer chasing her in
this time loop and she dies every time
she dies she has to relive this day over
again so it's kind of like kind of like
Groundhog Day don't look around look
kind of like that but part two which
what we just saw it happens again but
it's in a parallel universe and she
starts jumping through parallel
universes yeah turns out her friends who
worked up at the science lab had this
experiment going on and they built
basically they built a flux capacitor
and she got caught up in this time loop
and there's a lot of homage as - back to
the future - they even mentioned Back to
the Future - they even have Back to the
Future two posters in the guys room it
the tone is a lot like Back to the
Future
- yeah like I said it's now I will say I
would recommend seeing happy deathday
the first one yeah otherwise you're
gonna have a hard time following this
yeah I mean you'll probably be able to
follow it but it'll be easier if you see
the first one see you know what's going
on because they make a lot of references
back to the first one yeah and it will
make a lot more sense I saw the person I
had a hard time following it into
certain places yeah it's well it's very
complicated travel and step you know
looping days and stuff like that it's
gonna be coming and it's hard to keep
track of but I think the movie does a
good job and actually I'm gonna say this
the first one was a little bit more like
a sluggish slasher this one else
yeah like Groundhog Day if it was a
slasher right this one the first missile
parts of it it's a little bit it has
some slasher elements but it's actually
much more like a sci-fi sci-fi adventure
comedy the tones kind of all over the
place I mean there's horror movie
elements to it but it's not I think that
war was mostly suggested yeah I don't
think it's pg-13 yeah I don't think I'd
call it a straight horror movie it kind
of cross crosses genres but I think it
did that pretty successfully it's funny
you know it had like tension in it like
I said I had some horror movie stuff in
it but then you know it had like it's
crazy it's a you know what's weird I was
thinking of I mean definitely Back to
the Future Part 2 it also reminded me of
I don't know hey you guys remember this
movie I think it's from like 1985 called
my science project
where a guy find that thing in the
junkyard like it makes a I think Dennis
Hopper is another something it had a
little bit of fat but it has like a it
very much had a very 80s good tone to it
which I really liked about it I thought
it was fun as hell and actually I liked
this one a little better than in forums
it was better than the first because it
was a more expansive yeah it had a
bigger scope and the ending of it was a
lot better than the first
and it was weird too because it had
scenes that were actually surprisingly
touching I was gonna say I was gonna say
I was gonna say that the tongue was all
over the place I mean it is yeah it
would be try to have tension it would be
try to be scary and then it would be
like almost slapstick comedy lots of
humor in it it's it's like somebody was
huffing a lot of glue when they made it
but it wasn't bad I would say it was
above-average what they're showing
nowadays I think if I were a little bit
younger I think the target audience is a
little bit younger probably if I was a
little bit younger and I care enough to
go back and watch it a couple times and
sort it all
all out but really very complicated by
age I don't really give a [ __ ] yeah okay
[ __ ] your time travel but now it's okay
I mean it's it's if you had to go out
and see a movie this would be better
than staying home on it oh yeah yeah I
said there's a lot of shitty movies
going on and this isn't really one of
them yeah I actually really like this
one a lot I thought it was fun it was
good you know really funny like I liked
a lot of the gags and stuff like that
and I liked like I said I've liked that
they expanded the universe out because
the first one was good too but it was a
very you know it was a very close story
it was just me and she was like reliving
the same day and trying to catch her
killer and stuff but this one kind of
went off and all different you know
there were all these universities
usually like and she it was different
like in various ones that she had to
decide which one she wanted to go back
to and all this other kind of stuff if
you really might what I would say about
this is that if you really if you liked
the first one you'll really like this
one yeah the tone is very simple yeah
it's less like a horror movie and yeah
we're like back to the future style yes
I fi adventurer's a movie with some
horror elements I would think it's in
there I would say that this would be for
me I'd probably find it more satisfied
where you could watch it a couple of
times yes and yeah I mean and maybe see
some extras and [ __ ] about it yeah yeah
that's but it was a good theater movie
too it's just that some of it's some of
it was just like very confusing about
what had happened and I started to relax
I said you don't [ __ ] about here I'm
just gonna watch it well like I said I
would strongly think that you see the
person before you see this one because
otherwise you may be able to follow it
like if you pay attention yeah it's much
much easier to follow if you saw the and
we saw the first one like recently so
yeah so I remember like I remember some
of the stuff that they were frying right
yeah so but sometimes when she would die
I would forget that she died and she'd
relived that day again and I'm gonna be
a little bit different that's that's not
exactly the same yeah and then like well
what is she gonna do next but it does
kind of work it works out yeah you can
miss some of the movie and still enjoy
yeah yeah yes long as you like have a
handle on the RUS
you know and the through line of the
story like you know she has to they have
to like figure out how to close the loo
yeah you know so she can go back to the
universe she was originally in above
applause so as long as you keep that
through line it's like you you can still
enjoy it even if you don't yeah enjoy
all the subtleties because there's like
a lot of little yeah things that are
funny like if you so you're saying yes
on this one I'm saying I'm you're saying
yes I'm saying yeah yeah I like it a lot
like I said I actually liked it better
than person
[Music]
you
okay we just got done no see what was
the name of movies isn't it romantic
isn't it romantic this is a romantic
comedy and yeah it's a satire of a
romantic comedy where this is like a fat
girl fantasy where she gets hit on the
head and goes into a parallel universe
where everything's everything's perfect
like like in a romantic comedy except
she doesn't like it because she's trying
to get out it ends up it was good it was
within the genre of romantic comedy it's
a satire of romantic comedy that
fulfills romantic comedy yeah I was
almost gonna say I was I was thinking I
was like this is almost like the scream
of romantic comedies just like a parody
of the genre but also a really good
example of the genre like a really
energy but it's you know it's the kind
of movie that if you hate romantic
comedies which I generally do ya hate
him
but this is good this was actually very
very funny and like all of the I mean it
was just so cute like all of the troops
that they every 30 days every
stereotypical [ __ ] [ __ ] there and then
and rebel Wilson was so funny in it
because she would react the way a normal
person would react like when his stuff
is having its go that she was like that
it was super weird and you you know
wanted to escape it even though her life
was was super perfect now yeah but you
know it was just like I said it's it's a
romantic comedy yeah but it's one for
people that don't like them yes I would
say so
I'd never go see some [ __ ] like this but
you know I don't like romantic comedies
now this is [ __ ] funny man it was
hilarious and like everybody in it was
the lair and everybody did a great job
in the movie every character was done
right everybody performed the
performance was strong yeah everybody
and you could tell they had a lot of fun
with this movie making it that was
something especially like during the
last
sequence I think they must have had a
blast yeah this movie it looked like my
have got their life my hat's off to the
movie I mean I don't I don't like this
genre but this is a good movie this job
and like I said if you hate this genre
you should seriously give it a chance
because I was watching and I'm going you
know what this is basically a Jack Black
movie with a female lead it's very if
you like Jack Black movies that's
actually it's very close imagine if Jack
Black was playing a female role in a in
a in a romantic comedy this is kind of
how it would look like but of course he
isn't in it they got a real female doing
the role but I couldn't really seen Jack
Black dressed as a woman trying to do
this and parodying it was a bit even
funnier but the movie was pretty much
like that think about it yeah it busts
out in song and in song and dance and in
right where it's kind of [ __ ] it's
almost as as Aeneas [ __ ] Bollywood
yes like a Bollywood movie that [ __ ] was
funny and it was also kind of sweet to
it same time like you know she learned a
lesson yes so like I said it's still
adhered yes it was a feel-good movie it
was like making fun of it yeah it was a
feel-good movie but it had a bunch of
morality tales that were true and then
it it kind of [ __ ] with stereotypes
and made fun of stereotypes but the
stereotypes are kind of true too it was
just you got to see it to understand it
yeah I think the writing was actually
the writing was very good funny somebody
like great lines and like I said like
all those side characters were great
like all versions and and everybody else
that was in it was like really funny do
you I mean she's kind of the star of the
show but you know everybody it was
really good yes [ __ ] laugh they did a
good job as their as their as the
romantic male lead yeah you know it's
like the stereotypical alpha male he did
a great job at that
yeah so I just have to say you know I
recommend the movie yeah
I would as well like I said super funny
there's no reason not to see it if you
don't like the genre it's still yeah
because you could laugh at the genre
yeah yeah but it's still the genre yeah
it's almost kind of like the airplane of
[ __ ] yeah romantic you know because
airplane was doing this same thing but
they were doing it with the disaster
genre yeah you know but this is the
romantic comedy show yeah not April in
the name no yeah this was actually
really fun it was good
[Music]